(compressing)
- My girlfriend Katie
came in from Maine,
so great to spend some
quality time with her.
- Hi, my name is Katie.
- I know we're still young but,
I get the feeling that
Katie, she might be the one.
(laughter)
Tyree made me really
uncomfortable,
the way he was looking
at me and Katie.
Something in his eyes
that kinda scared me,
and it wasn't appropriate.
(laughter)
- Just a couple minutes bro.
- And then there was that
one night in my room.
(hip-hop beat)
- Hey, get your ass
up, I need that bed.
I got company, my man
Lysol fresh out the joint.
- [Lysol] Yeah.
- Hello Lysol.
- [Lysol] Sup.
- No problem Tyree,
come on Katie let's go.
- [Lysol] No, nah nah
son, she can stay.
- You know what Chad,
I'm gonna stay here.
Lysol and Tyree, they're
just genuinely nice guys.
- What you waitin' for man,
get your fat ass outta here
'fore I cut some
bacon off your back.
(laughter)
- Can we stop the tape?
- [Tyree] Yeah, we gonna
send that back to the joint,
she don't know how we livin'
out here, you know what I mean?
- I saw Katie with
Tyree and Lysol
and, um, I worked
my way through it.
- [Tyree] Yeah, do your
thing there, doggy, yeah.
(crying)
(laughing)
- Yo, would you hold it down?
We're trying to
make love over here.
(laughter)
It's good to be alone for a
minute in the confession room.
Niggas is wildin'.
(chanting)
- I remember that we
were all joking around
and Tron got me
in a sleeper hold.
(cheering)
I don't think he
meant to hurt me,
but I'll be honest I don't
remember a whole lot after that.
(sizzling)
(cheering)
- [Tyree] We goin' to take
Chad upstairs and tuck him in.
- Oh okay, that's nice yeah.
- Be careful if you
get a sleeper hold,
because the next day your
anus will really hurt.
(laughter)
You know, I'll admit
it, when my dad came by
I was a little bit concerned.
Hey guys, I'd like to
introduce you all to my dad.
- I brought some brownies.
- They got weed in 'em?
(laughter)
- I felt bad for that white boy,
but his daddy shouldn'ta
looked at her like that,
so you know.
- 'Cause I don't like
how you looked at me,
why you gotta look
at me like that?
- Zondra, I apologize, I don't
know how I'm looking at you.
- [Zondra] Like that.
- Like what?
- Oh look, look he doin' it.
- [Dad] I'll look over here.
- Don't look at me.
- He don't know how
to talk to people.
- Why you gotta be
lookin' at me white man?
- I'm not looking at
anyone, if someone could...
(laughter)
I've been stabbed.
- Blah, blah blah.
- Zondra, I've been stabbed,
and I don't know what I did.
- You came in a house with
six wild, that's what you did.
(laughter)
I, I'm bleeding.
- [Chad] Hey guys, what's
going on out there?
(laughter)